he is the host of CR TV's Levin TV the
host of life liberty Levin right here on
the Fox News Channel by the way the
number one show on Sunday night by far
we call them the great one Mark Levin
mark I'm just gonna throw it right to
you we've seen a lot over the years I've
been doing radio 30 years I've been at
the Fox News Channel since October 1996
it's never been this awful and it's been
bad a lot of times a couple things here
first of all notice there's no blue
dress here how do these three accusers
there's not a single eye witness there's
not a single corroborating witness
there's not a single shred of evidence
so that's what they have in common no
case which is exactly why the Democrats
believe that only the Senate Judiciary
Committee the Bill of Rights don't apply
only the Senate Judiciary Committee the
Constitution doesn't apply no due
process no presumption of innocence
because they have to make that case
because you want to know why I believe
Brett Kavanaugh I believe Brett
Kavanaugh the Democrats they're lawyers
they're operatives the Senate their
staffers all scheming around in the
shadows they've come up with literally
nothing tangible or concrete the reason
why they blow this off that it's not a
court of laws because that's how
totalitarians think and so you have
people who make accusation this isn't
about women's rights it's not even about
women there are millions of millions of
women out there many of them watching
your show my wife my mother my daughter
my stepdaughter my my mother-in-law and
so forth who don't believe any of this
there's tens of millions of women who
find this entire spectacle it's not a
hearing it's a spectacle it's a Roman
Colosseum they're throwing up to the
lines they find this disgusting liberals
don't speak for women did Ted Kennedy
speak for Mary Jo Kopechne II did Bill
Clinton speak for all the women that he
sexually assaulted I don't think so
now people keep saying Brett Kavanaugh
had six FBI background investigations
how many background investigations did
miss Ford have zero how about the other
accusers how many FBI background
investigations that they have
zero as a matter of fact it's very
interesting to me all these left-wing
democrat lawyers who represent these
accusers they know where the montgomery
county police department is they haven't
walked a single one of their clients
into that law enforcement office to file
a complaint against mr. Cavanaugh they
keep talking about the FBI the
jurisdiction is Montgomery County
Maryland boys and you know where it is
why don't you go ahead and file your
complaints there and I'll tell you why
because then the rule of law actually
kicks in and they don't want the rule of
law to apply and I'm starting to wonder
about this Senate Judiciary Committee
Sean they're either filled with perverts
or totalitarians it's one or the other
they are gleeful they're exciting
they're salivated all over this it is a
disgusting spectacle now a couple of
other things I want to mention which is
this look at this latest example this
lady comes forward her ex-boyfriend
comes for it and Politico reports he
doesn't believe a word that she says
avenatti a vanadis back the
slip-and-fall porn lawyer the Democrats
embrace him they embraced the argument
mizramirez didn't want to come forward
the Democrats staff go find her try and
drag her forward no corroborating
witnesses her memory suddenly is is HD
color clear but she's not going to
testify then we have dr. Ford I've never
understood this dr. Ford issue she
wanted to remain private so where does
she go to the Washington Post now here's
the thing I keep hearing all over
television of course I want to hear what
dr. Ford has to say of course she has a
right to sit well of course we all want
to hear what dr. Ford has to say but dr.
Ford is an adult she's a professor she
has a PhD she's made an allegation
against another human being
she needs to be cross-examined
aggressively she's not the bubble lady
she needs to be questioned when somebody
accuses somebody of a horrific crime 36
years after the fact said nothing to
anybody else that we know of at least
there's no witness of any kind the Ford
people she mentioned say no that's not
true ms ford needs to be questioned
and thoroughly and I want the American
people to understand something this
entire process from Bork to Clarence
Thomas and all the rest of the now has
been hijacked by the radical left look
at the Democrats on this committee it's
the most radical bunch imaginable
you've got Gillibrand you've got
Feinstein Durbin Kamala Harris Booker
all from dark blue states one-party
states who are trying to appeal the most
radical crazies in their party we need
to stand up to this all right mark levin
thank you and could you imagine that ten
party's boys lining up drugging women
nobody ever said anything and it
happened more weekends unbelievable